[Musik]
guten abend wir melden uns mit einem
kurzen heute-journal spezial direkt
danach kann phileas fogg weiter in 80
tagen um die welt reisen in unserer
realen welt ist corona das beherrschende
thema die konferenz von bund und ländern
hat dazu heute ihre beschlüsse gefasst
die im wesentlichen nicht anders
aussehen als das was gestern schon
durchgesickert war etwa zu den kontakt
beschränkungen auch für geimpfte die
mehrheit der runde will sie erst nach
weihnachten einführen und auf einige
maßnahmen die das lka heute empfohlen
hat wird vorerst ganz verzichtet dazu
gleich noch ein gespräch mit der neuen
regierenden bürgermeisterin von berlin
franziska giffey
doch zunächst berichtet bin die fesche
olaf scholz hat omikron analysiert und
ist nun gekommen und die konsequenzen
mitzuteilen wir wollen seine
konsequenzen und analyse nicht so recht
zusammenpassen über die neue gefahr die
neue corona variante sie ist nach
einschätzung der fachleute was die
infektionen betrifft noch aggressiver
das ist nach derzeitiger einschätzung
bestenfalls nur eine frage von wenigen
wochen ist diese virusvariante sich auch
bei uns durchsetzen wird
deshalb müssen wir uns auch jetzt darauf
vorbereiten
corona macht keine weihnachtspause eine
weihnachtspause aber will der
bundeskanzler dem land können wie angela
merkel im vergangenen jahr der
maßnahmenkatalog bleibt über weihnachten
beim alten 2g im einzelhandel 3g am
arbeitsplatz in bussen bahnen und
fernzügen kontakt beschränkungen beim
treff mit ungeimpften das heißt treff
mit höchstens zwei personen eines
weiteren haushalts
nach weihnachten werden clubs und
diskotheken geschlossen
grossveranstaltungen ohne publikum
abgehalten das silvesterfeuerwerk wird
verboten und erstmals wird es kontakt
beschränkung für geimpfte und genesene
geben maximal zehn personen ausgenommen
kinder unter 14 jahren man setzt auf
impfbereitschaft und appelle
wir müssen uns schützen und unsere
angehörigen
wenn wir das tun mit all der vernunft
die uns als menschen gegeben ist werden
wir auch gut durch die nächste krone
willkommen nicht alle glauben dass das
reicht hinter den kulissen hat das
kräftig gerappelt zwischen lka-chef
vieler kanzler scholz und minister
lauterbach das lka hatte kurz vor der
mpk maximale kontakt beschränkungen
empfohlen und war damit nicht allein
ich habe heute von bundeskanzler scholz
in dieser richtung führung
bestellen ja wir brauchen alle
instrumente
zurück
und ich finde auch einen lock down kann
man nicht ausschließen es kam anders
deshalb geben baden württemberg und
sachsen ihren unmut zu protokoll sie
halten die maßnahmen für nicht
weitgehend genug und sie fordern
kurzfristig die erneute feststellung der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite durch den bundestag was
passiert ist eine so starken krone
ausbruch gibt dass wir in dem bereich
der kritischen infrastruktur
teilweise zusammenbrüche haben das ist
das szenario über das gesprochen wird
und gleichzeitig können wir nicht eine
ganze reihe von dingen handeln weil die
bundesgesetzliche regelung dafür nicht
vorhanden dass die dinge passen nicht
zusammen am 17 januar soll die nächste
mpk sein weihnachten sein letztes jahr
kein pandemie treiber gewesen sagt olaf
scholz und helmi krohn doch für viel
aggressiver analyse konsequenz nicht
deckungsgleich und
das berlin ist uns live die neue frisch
gebackene frisch gekürte und vereidigte
regierende bürgermeisterin von berlin
zugeschaltet franziska gefallen guten
abend
ein interessanter tag für sie kaum im
amt dann sind sie schon ko vorsitzender
dieser krisen mpk die große frage ist ob
die maßnahmen die jetzt mehrheitlich
verhängt werden reichen in hamburg zum
beispiel sieht man das nicht so hamburg
wird schon am 24
dezember mit kontakt beschränkungen auch
mit sperrstunden beginnen planen sie
ähnliches in der ebenfalls großen großen
stadt berlin
wir haben eine vielzahl der maßnahmen
die heute auch im beschluss schon
festgehalten sind in berlin bereits in
der umsetzung wir haben die zwei
gelungen überall umgesetzt im
einzelhandel aber ich mache ja viel
kontakt beschränkungen also die neu
hinzu gekommen und wie wir in
schwingungen werden wir am donnerstag
übermorgen im senat beraten und mit der
umsetzung voraussichtlich dann am 28
dezember auch starten wir rufen trotzdem
unsere gesamte bevölkerung dazu auf
weihnachten und die feiertage eben auch
auf eigene verantwortliche kontakt
beschränkung einzugehen da sind alle
bürgerinnen und bürger gefragt und wir
werden diese umsetzung dann zur nächsten
woche machen das ak hatte ja empfohlen
auch darüber hinaus zu gehen also
erstens schneller zu machen zweitens
restaurants auch zu schließen
weihnachtsferien für die kinder und
schulkinder zu verlängern und
universitäten wieder auf distanz
unterricht zu gehen reisebeschränkungen
zu verhängen warum sind sie dahinter
zurückgeblieben heute in der runde ist
da die gefahrenanalyse dann doch eine
andere die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
hat sich ja bezogen auf die empfehlung
vom expertenrat die am sonntagabend jahr
veröffentlicht worden sind auch und auf
dieser basis ist der beschlusstext
erarbeitet wurden und diese expertenrat
hat er eine einstimmige empfehlung
abgegeben und auf dieser basis ist heute
auf der beschluss gefasst worden
insofern ist das schon nachvollzogen
weiß expertin experten uns empfohlen
haben und ich finde jede maßnahme muss
auch verhältnismäßig sein und in
schritten auch vorgehen und die dinge
die jetzt beschlossen worden sind müssen
auf ihre wirksamkeit auch betrachtet
werden und deswegen ist es in ordnung
heute diese maßnahmen auch so getroffen
zu haben die reihenfolge ist eigentlich
so dass der expertenrat allgemein gesagt
hat es gibt handlungsbedarf und wir
brauchen starke kontakt beschränkungen
wir brauchen sie den nächsten tag er hat
aber nicht ausgeführt wie das dann
operational sozusagen aussehen soll das
wiederum hat dann die zuständige behörde
robert-koch-institut rk ii gemacht und
das eben konkretisiert aber von diesen
konkreten vorschlägen die ja nicht
abweichen von dem was der expertenrat
gesagt hat er gar keine konkreten
vorschläge gemacht hat weil sie jetzt
als politiker doch ab warum ist die
wissenschaft also alarmiert war als die
politik die politik ist auch alarmiert
wir sehen dass wir diese situation haben
wir deshalb wird auch die impfkampagne
dass boost dann alles auch in den
feiertagen weiter vorangebracht das sind
der 30 millionen impfungen bis zum
jahresende vorgesehen das wird aller
voraussicht nach auch geschafft werden
hier in berlin auch über die feiertage
voll ausbauen wir sind an den
unterschiedlichsten stellen da aktiv und
natürlich werden diese kontakt
beschränkung auch greifen auch für die
großveranstaltung für all das was heute
besprochen worden ist und das sind schon
sehr gravierende einschneidende
maßnahmen aber noch einmal wir müssen
auch darauf achten dass jede maßnahme
die wir treffen verhältnismäßig ist und
deswegen ist heute einen schritt in
diese richtung gegangen worden und ich
finde das richtig zunächst wer ist ein
verhältnismäßig wenn dann bei uns quasi
die kritische infrastruktur mehr oder
weniger zusammen klappt also in london
hört man von menschen die dort leben
dauert inzwischen stunde bisschen
rettungswagen kommt was auch daran liegt
dass so viele rettungssanitäter selbst
erkrankt sind wir haben genau diese
aufgabe jetzt das ist ja heute auch
beschlossen worden dass wir mit unseren
akteuren der kritischen infrastruktur
eine anpassung ihrer kann die mir eh
aktionspläne auch vornehmen das werden
wir tun und da geht es natürlich genau
darum auszuloten welche maßnahmen
getroffen werden sollte es soweit kommen
dass eben
akteure mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter der
kritischen infrastruktur nicht in der
weise mehr einsatzfähig sind das werden
wir hier auch in berlin in 1
bundesländern mit unseren aktuellen der
kritischen infrastruktur besprechen das
wir uns vorbereiten auf endlich kann man
sich dann darauf vorbereiten also auch
sanitäter fahren ja s-bahn u-bahn haben
familien sollte dann isoliert werden
oder im lkw fahrer die lebensmittel
transportieren feuerwehrleute die leben
ja alle auch ein normales leben wie will
man die davor schützen sich anzustecken
wenn diese sony-konsole ansteckend ist
es geht darum dass wir alle auf unnötige
kontakte verzichten
verantwortungsbewusst weihnachten feiern
dass wenn wir uns treffen im privaten
bereich mit freundinnen und freunde mit
familie eben zusätzlich zum impfen das
testen machen dass wir uns bewusst sein
lassen weil die chance dann viel viel
größer ist geschützt zu sein und dass
wir auf alle unnötigen kontakte
verzichten darum geht es jetzt und aber
1000 rosen davon dann mit 50 leuten aber
zuhause nummer 10
also
wir sind die frau slomka es ist ja
wichtig dass wir gerade im privaten
bereich wo eben diese kontrollen nicht
erfolgen können in den restaurants
müssen sie ihren nachweis vorzeigen und
dort sein zu können das ist im privaten
bereich eben nicht so und wir wissen
dass im privaten bereich die einstellung
besonders groß sind und deswegen ist es
auch wichtig im privaten bereich eben zu
unterbinden dass jetzt große
silvesterparty stattfinden zum beispiel
dafür ist nicht die zeit und das ist ein
ganz entscheidender punkt um auch die
infektionsrisiken zu reduzieren sagte
neuer regierende bürgermeisterin von
berlin die jetzt auch direkt in die
krise wird eingestiegen ist dunkin frau
gefallen englisch das war es erstmal in
diesem kurzen heute-journal spezial
ausführlicher melden wir uns dann um 23
45 wieder aktuelle informationen zum
thema finden sie aber natürlich immer
auch online auf zdf heute und jetzt wird
erstmal weiter in 80 tagen um die welt
gereist dabei bot unterhaltung auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]